what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the broad categories of where
the federal government gets its revenue
and also the broad categories of where
it spends its revenue and now when we
talk about revenue for the federal
government that primarily comes in the
form of taxes and what we see in this
visual it shows the four basic types of
taxes that the federal government
collects
you have individual income taxes which
you are probably familiar with if you
ever get a pay stub and if you thought
you were making
let's say a thousand dollars in a pay
period you might see your paycheck is
closer to six hundred dollars because
there might be individual income taxes
taken out at both the federal and the
state level
then you have payroll taxes and unless
you are an employer you might not be
familiar with payroll taxes above and
beyond your individual income taxes your
employer also pays taxes called payroll
taxes now these are primarily to pay for
things like social security medicare
unemployment insurance and some of you
are saying well don't they take that out
of my individual income taxes as well
and the answer is yes but above and
beyond what is individually paid by you
they also take payroll taxes to fund
that corporate taxes are taxes on
corporations profits and excise taxes
which you don't hear folks talk a lot
about these days but these are taxes on
things like gasoline or alcohol and
tobacco or airline tickets that are
usually baked into those products and
those taxes can oftentimes go to the
federal government
now pause this video and see if you see
any interesting trends this visual here
shows the breakdown between these four
taxes for the federal government's
revenue and how it's changed from 1950
all the way to 2015.
well it looks like individual income
taxes as a percent of total government
revenue has stayed roughly stable but
what you see is that payroll taxes have
grown dramatically while corporate taxes
have shrunk payroll taxes have gone from
11 percent of the federal government's
revenue in 1950 to nearly one-third of
the federal government's revenue in
2015. corporate taxes have gone down
from 26.5
all the way down to 10.6 percent and
excise taxes are a very small percentage
they used to be a significant part but
they are now a very small part of total
government revenue
now one thing to keep in mind this
visual over here just shows the
breakdown it's not showing the absolute
level if you were seeing the absolute
level of government revenue you would
see that grow as the nation's gdp grew
as well
but in big categories where does that
revenue get spent
well this is a similar diagram that
shows the breakdown of outlays by the
federal government from 1962 all the way
and these are going into projected
outlays to 2020 at the time of this
video we are right over here in 2017 and
this chart was made in 2016 so it was
made around this time but you see a
couple of big categories you first see
the mandatory outlays and in parentheses
it says on autopilot what does that mean
well these are commitments that the
federal government has already made by
law to people these are things like
entitlements like social security like
medicare and one interesting trend is
these have grown in 1962 from 25 percent
of the total federal budget to a
projected almost two-thirds of the
federal budget in 2020.
now the discretionary outlays are things
that when we talk about the
appropriations committees in the senate
or the house this is what they're
debating where to spend the money and
even though it might sound something
that's just a nice to have there's some
pretty important things in the
discretionary budget things like
military expenditure and as you can see
the discretionary budget has gone from
over two-thirds of federal outlays to a
little under one-fourth projected in
2020 and then this top category net
interest well the federal government has
a debt and anyone who has a debt tends
to pay interest on that debt and so many
people will often categorize this as a
mandatory outlay as well because we need
to pay the interest on that debt even
though it's not officially a mandatory
outlay
and to see how significant these
entitlement programs are and how big of
an impact they have not just on the
federal government's budget but as a
percentage of gdp
we have this visual right over here and
once again this is projecting well into
the future this chart was created in
2016 so right about here but you can see
that these mandatory outlays as a
percentage of the gdp here so this is
not just as a percentage of the budget
they are growing and growing and growing
and expected to keep on growing while
total revenue as a percentage of gdp is
expected to stay flat and take all of
this with a grain of salt this is based
on assumptions made at the time when
this diagram was made if we have varying
levels of economic growth or the tax
policies change it's possible that the
total revenue as a percentage of gdp
might change
also if there are changes to some of
these entitlement programs like social
security or the health care programs or
some of the cost assumptions baked into
this chart changes well then this
diagram might change but if you assume
the data in this visual here and the
source is the white house in 2016 you
see that the mandatory outlays from
these entitlement programs and the net
interest which is also essentially
mandatory these are going to take up all
of the revenue that the federal
government collects
and so if the federal government wants
to do anything above and beyond those
things discretionary spending and once
again some of this discretionary
spending is pretty important like the
military well then they would have to
run a deficit in those years to fund
those things or they would have to
increase the total revenue and the thing
is even once we get past this point
going to the 2040s all the way to 2050s
it gets worse and worse and worse so
something has got to give here